[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزوايا هو من
جميع جوانبه
يتجه لمؤسسات التابعه لهذه القيادات سيتجه
رئيس المجلس الرئاسي اليمني يؤكد للعربيه
الا تغير في الموقف الامريكي من الحوثي
رغم قناه لايران
ترقبون لاستقاله ماسك من اداره تويتر بعد
خسارته في استطلاعا للاستفتاء على بقائه
في اداره المنصات
كاسبر سكريبر
الاردن
معان ويعلن تصفيات قاتل العميد لبيحه في
مداهمه قتلت ثلاثه رجال امنه
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه تتابعونا ايضا
[موسيقى]
اسطوره التانجو ميسي
يقرر الاستمرار في امتاع جمهوره الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نبدا النشره من المقابله التي
اجرتها العربيه مع رئيس المجلس الرئاسي
اليمني رشاد العليمي الذي اكد للعربيه على
تغيير في الموقف الامريكي من الحوثي رغم
قناعه البنتاجون بتبعيه الايرانه واضاف
الاعلامي في برنامج مقابله خاصه الذي
يبثوه او بوسه على العربيه انا الحكومه
اليمنيه الشرعيه نفذت ما يخصها بالهدنه
على عكس الحوت كما اكد العليمي ان
الميليشيات الحوثيه رفضت تمديد الهدنه
مشيرا الى ان هذه الهدنه كانت هشه
الحوثي لم تلتزم ببنوجها
[موسيقى]
ان نقنع المجتمع الدولي وفي المقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان هناك دعم ايراني غير محدود لهذه
الجماعه
وكان ونسلم ملفات بوثائق وادله متعدده
وكل مكان ياتي وفي امريكا الى صنعاء كلنا
نسلم
ها للمتمردين فيصل
ولكن دائما يقولون ان الادله غير كافيه
قال نحن مقتنعين في البنتاجون وفي الشيعيه
ان هذه جماعه تتبع ايران ومدعومه من ايران
ولكن من يقنع البيت الابيض
لرئيس الوزراء اليمني اهلا بك سيد علي
معنا الليله يعني اهم ما جاء في كلام رئيس
المجلس الرئاسي اليمني في هذه المقابله
الحصريه للعربيه بانه لا تغيير في الموقف
الامريكي رغم قناعه البنتاجون بتبعيات
جماعه الحوثي لايران وبالتالي لماذا هذا
التعنت الامريكي برايك
اولا مساء الخير لكل المشاهدين الكلام
موقف الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه اداره
بايدين اداره الحزب الديمقراطي
الامريكي في الواقع هي محيره مواقف محيره
هم
بيتحدثوا للعالم كله بانهم ضد الدور
الايراني
ولكنهم في الوقت نفسه لا يحركون ساكنا
امام ايران وادوات ايران
والدليل على هذا اليمن نلاحظ بان بيدور في
اليمن واضح ان هناك جماعه ميليشاويه
متمرده تحصل على دعم
ايراني واسع النطاق تتحصل على الاموال
ويتحصل على ال ال الصواريخ ويتحصل على
الطائرات المسيره والذخائر والاسلحه
المختلفه خلافا وضدا على قرارات مجلس
الامن
والامريكان يدركون هذا بل وكان لهم ايضا
مساهمات في ضبط عدد من هذه الشحنات التي
ترسل من ايران الى اليمن ولكنهم مع ذلك لم
يتقدموا في موقفهم باتجاه اخذ موقف عملي
حقيقي ضد هذا الدور الذي تلعبه ايران في
اليمن
بلدان اخرى مثل لبنان مثل العراق ولكن
يعني هل تشارك السيد الاعلامي ما قاله
بانه المصالح الامريكيه هي من تحكم همم
موقف امريكا يعني نتحدثون عن مصالح كثيره
يمكن من ضمنها همم في العوده الى همم
العوده الى النووي يعني
انا اعتقد بان المصالح الامريكيه لم تعد
هي لوحدها ما يحدد الموقف الامريكي صار
هناك عوامل اخرى
تؤثر في الموقف الامريكي المصالح طبعا تظل
هي مثل ماذا تؤثر رقم واحد ولكن المصالح
البتروليه المصالح الاقتصاديه
الاستراتيجيه لا تزال هي ال ال العامل
الرئيسي الذي يحدد مواقف الولايات المتحده
من الواقع في المنطقه بشكل عام ولكن هناك
الان مؤثرات اخرى منها مثلا ابعاد
ايدولوجيه الان الاداره الديمقراطيه
الجديده بقياده همم بيدن هناك بعض الاطراف
لديه توجهات ايديولوجيه هذه التوجيهات
تؤثر في الموقف الامريكي ولهذا هي تناسب
العداء لي يعني اولا هي تتواضع مع ايران
وتتواضع مع نظامها
الديكتاتوري ومع ماتوا ما يما وهذا النظام
من من انتهاكات واساءات للانسانيه ولكنها
تتشدد في غايه تتشدد ضد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي تنفتح الان على ال- ال- ال-
على العصر وتتخذ اجراءات يعني ستؤدي الى
انتقال ليس السعوديه لوحدها همم الى العصر
ولكنها ستساعد المنطقه كلها الان السعوديه
تنظم مصادر الارهاب الفكريه والماليه لكن
هذا لا يعجب هذا التيار الهيدروجي الذي
يعني غير راضي عما يدور في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالتبعيه لهذا الموقف
نلاحظ بان هذا التيار يتبنى موقفا معيانا
من الحرب في اليمن ويقف الى جانب الحوثيين
ويقف الى جانب ايران ولهذا نلاحظ مقترحاته
والمشاريع اللي يقدمها في الكونغرس وغيره
همم ودعمه حتى للجماعات الحوثيه التي تنشط
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
نلاحظ بانها فعلا هي لا يعني همم تختلف او
تتناقض مع المصالح الامريكيه المصالح التي
تستدعي فعلا من الولايات المتحده ان تحافظ
على الامن في المنطقه ان تحافظ على ال ال
الطريق الملاحه الدوليه الذي يمر بباب
المندب والبحر الاحمر والتي صارت تهدد
بشكل قوي من جانب ايران من خلال اداه
الحوثيه التي تهدد الان البحر العربي
البلاحه في البحر العربي والبحر الاحمر
هذا مواقف هذه مواقف غريبه امريكا ايضا في
الوقت الذي هي يعني تتخذ مواقف همم يعني
همم تقول بانها مؤيده لانتفاضه الشعب
الايراني ضد حكم الملالي ولكنها ماذا تقدم
للشعب الايراني الان ماذا تقدم لا تبحث عن
اتفاق تبحث عن اتفاق
همم يتعلق بالملف النووي الايراني الذي
سيفتح الباب لحصول هذا النظام على عشرات
المليارات سكر كي يواجه الى ادواته في
المنطقه يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا جزيلا لك
علي اسرار المستشار السياسي والاعلامي
لرئيس الوزراء اليمني
[موسيقى]
بنعم صوت مستخدم تويتر لتنحي الماسك من
رئاسه شركه توتر التي يمتلكها بعد ان وضع
الملياردار الامريكي مصيره في ايدي
المشاركين في هذا التصويت ونشر ماسك
تغريده كتب فيها هل علي التنحي عن رئاسه
تويتر هذا هو السؤال مع احتمالين هما نعم
وكله متعهدا بالالتزام بالنتيجه اسفرت
نتيجه هذا التصويت عن موافقه
57.5 صوته بنعم هو 42.5 صوت
اذا مشاهدينا في استطلاع هذا الاستطلاع
الذي شارك فيه اكثر من 17 مليون شخص نشر
الملياردير الذي كان اغنى رجل في العالم
هذا الاستطلاع بعد اقراره على ما يبدو
بانه ارتكب خطا من خلال منعه مستخدمين
تويتر من الترويج لحساباتهم على منصات
اجتماعيه منافسه غرد قائلا سيحصل تصويت
على تغييرات كبرى في قواعد الاستخدام
اعتذر لن يتكرر ذلك واثر ماسك الجده
المرات عده منذ تواليه رئاسه تويتر قبل
السبع قليله بما يشمل صرفه للكثير من
العمال في التويتر اعاده بعض الحسابات
حسابات اليمين المتطرف وحجب حسابات صحفيه
بعد فتره وجيزه من تواليه لرئاسه المنصه
اعلى لنا ان التوتر ستتقادى ثمانيه
دولارات شهريا مقابل توثيق الحساب لكنه
الطره الى تعليق خطه وتر بلو بعد توفيق
كثير من الحسابات المزيفه ثم اعيد العمل
بهذه الخدمه مؤخرا في الرابع من نوفمبر
قلم ماسك ان الشركه تخسر اربعه ملايين
دولار في اليوم كم استغنت تويتر عن نصفي
موظفيها البالغ عددهم
7,500 موظف
[موسيقى]
منذ انحط الطائر الازرق في قفص الملياردير
ماسك لم تنفك التغييرات تطارد تويتر اخرها
حظر الحسابات المستخدمه للترويج لمنصات
تواصل اجتماعيا اخرى مثل الفيسبوك
وانستغرام ومستوديون المنافس لتويتر خطوه
لاقت معارضه واسعه خاصه من المؤسس المشارك
لتويتر جاك دورسي الذي وصفها بالخطوه التي
لا معنى لها القرار جاء بعد ايام قليله من
تعليق حسابات صحفيين على تويتر بحجه عدم
امتثالهم لسياسته الجديده الدوكسينج
والمتعلقه بنشر المعلومات
ومع الضغوط التي تعرض لها وجد ماسك نفسه
امام خيار الطرح استطلاع راي على حسابه
لاعاده تفعيل الحسابات او ابقائها مغلقه
عمليه تعليق الحسابات اثاره غضب الحكومات
والافراد حول العالم معتبرين انها تقويم
لحريه الصحافه وتناقض ما دعى اليه ماسك
نفسه عند استحوده على تويتر
في ظل كل الاحداث المكثفه التي مر بها
تويتر خلال اقل من شهرين من تولي ماسك
المنصب والقيود التي وضعها على المستخدمين
بينما يحاول جعلهم ان يدفعوا مقابل
الخدمات يتجه العديد من المستخدمين الى
منصه اخرى بحسب اكسيوس
ضغوط كبيره خلال فتره قصيره ربما كانت
السبب وراء استطلاع الراي الذي نشره ماسك
على تويتر
متسائلا اذا ما كان يجب ان يتخلى عن منصبه
في تويتر لقد يجعله خارجه اسوار المنصه
الاكثر شعبيه الى عمر العربيه
سانوزي كاليفورنيا دكتور
في هذه اللحظات من رئاسه مجلس اداره فطر
الطائر الازرق لم يعد يراسه تويتر
بالبدايه
في مثل يقول لك اعطي الخبز الخبز ولو اكل
نصفه هذه هي المشكله اللي حاصل مع الين
ماسك لفتره طويله يعني اساء استخدام مركزه
وسائل ناس كثيرا وناس كثير فقدوا اعمالهم
بسبب انه ما عنده خبره في اداره منصه
للتواصل الاجتماعي وهذه نتيجه حتميه
وبالتالي هل يعني وصل ماسك الى قناعه بانه
كل الاجراء
ات التي تمت
خان تصريح لعمال من يعني حجمه
صحفيين كبار ايضا كان هناك تهديد واضح من
المفوضيه الاوروبيه بانه يعني حصل هذا
الموضوع هو خطير جدا وقد نتخذ اجراءات
وعقوبات على تويتر هل يحاول انقاذ تويتر
وهل سينجف فعليا بذلك نعم كلامك سليم اختي
الكريمه جدا لانه هو خلق اعداء في فتره
بسيطه يعني 50 يوم الى الان من يوم تولى
اداره تويتر اضافه الى انه حاول الاسبوع
اللي فات انه يقنع مستثمرين يستثمره في
تويتر لانه ما في دخل فالمستثمرين رفضوا
انه على الوضع اللي هو فيه وكان شرط من
شروطه منه اذا بتحبنا نستثمر لازم تغير
الاداره فهذا هو السبب انه لا جاء الى هذا
الاستبيان او الاستفتاء على اساس يخرج
بطريقه
سيكون برايك الرئيس القادم لتويتر هل
سيكون من المؤسسه ذاتها الشخص او شخص من
الخارج يثق ماسك باداراته
اي شخص بخلفيه في اداره
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي بيكون شخص مناسب
اا المشكله انه همم
السمعه التويتر يعني بتطلب فتره طويله حتى
يعني ترجع الثقه مره ثانيه فال- وال-
المشكله الثانيه انه همم يعني مدى تدخل
همم في الاداره حتى لانه استقال برده هو
صاحب الشركه ففي اشياء كثيره لازم توضح
قبل ما حتى احد يقبل المركز هذا
ما الذي يجب ان يتم توضيحه يعني كي تعود
الثقه التي فقدت ب 50 يوم
استهدافه لاشخاص بعينهم زي الصحفيين هذا
الشيء غير مقبول ثانيا ال ال اللخبطه اللي
عملها في الاشاره الزرقاء هذه خلقت مشاكل
كثيره ودخل فيها في عداوه مع ابل
ثالثا انه ما عنده خبره انت محتاج شخص
يكون عنده خبره في منصات التفاصيل
الاجتماعي يفهم بالضبط انه انت في فرق بين
انك تدير شركه تصنع سيارات وشركه تصنع
اراء يعني التواصل الاجتماعي تتعامل مع
بشر عواطفهم وردود افعالهم لكن في
السيارات انت تبيع السيارات وتخلص في
تويتر انت تبدا العلاقه لما الشخص يفتح
الحساب على تويتر وهذا هو الفرق وبالتالي
ما برايك بعد قليل سنشاهد ابرز القرارات
التي اتخذها الان ماسك بفتره تواليه رئاسه
تويتر ولكن برايك ما اخطر اجراء قام به
يعني كان هذا الذي
دمر كل شيء اذا صحى تعبير
اولا لما رجع حسابات ناس بينشروا معلومات
مظله وناس تم حجمهم او حضرهم بسبب
تصرفاتهم
ويعني والقشه اللي اللي قاسم الظاهر
البعير هي ال- همم حضر الصحفيين في صحفيه
حظرها لانه سالته سؤال يعني مشهوره صحفيه
هذه معروفه عندنا هنا سالته سؤال فحضرها
على طول هذا مش تصرف انسان يعني مسؤول في
شركه كبيره زي هذه
مساهموا تسلم هي الشركه شركه السيارات
التابعه لا الان ماسك هاجموا ماسك عندما
اشترى تويتر وحتى انه سعر اسهم تسلا منذ
بدايه عام 2022 وحتى الان انخفضت
اكبر مستثمر في تسلا وهو ملياردير من
سنغافوره همم الاسبوع اللي فات ارسل رساله
واضحه انه انا افضل انه يكون رئيس اخر
لتسله لانه انت مشغول باللعب الجديده
تبعتك هذا كان كلامه فالى ان يعني تركز
معنا على تسله احنا كسره همم تقريبا نصف
قيمتها بسبب انه مش مركز مع تسله صرف
انتباه كله الى تويتر سائل السمعه
النوعيه نفسها تبعت تبعت الناس صارت تتجنب
نقطه اخرى الكلمه عندنا هنا في سلك غالي
في وادي السيليكون في كاليفورنيا لها اكبر
سوق يعني خفضت واشتروات تسلم بسبب سمعت
همم المصري
دكتور احمد لعبه يعني هذا المصطلح همم
سمعناه باكثر من مكان واا باكثر من تحليل
عن كيف يتصرف الماسك على تويتر عن قراراته
عن تغريدات ايضا لماذا
ما في حساب يعني من ناحيته وهو ينظر اليه
على انه انسان ملكه
وانه بيتصرف وبياخذ القرارات من غير ما حد
يسالوا وفي نفس الوقت يعني بيغير فيها
يمين ويسار من غير ما يفكر في في توابع
القرارات فاصبحت من ناحيته انه هذه شيء
جديد بيستكشفه
ولكن انت بتتكلم على منصه عملاقه لها
تاثير على مستوى العالم ما اعتقد انه كان
مدرك الشيء هذا كان يعتقد نفسه انه ممكن
يتصرف من غير اي توابل
طيب
همم ابقى معي دكتور احمد سنستمع الى
الماسك
ساليب فقط
المحفظه التي تحتوي على كل المفاتيح
وربما هذا امر ينطوي على تمكين الافراد
المتعاملين عبر الشبكات وان يكون لديهم
مفاتيح خاصه عبر هذه المحفظه التي اتحدث
عنها همم بالنسبه همم عمله الرقميه
اه اه
سنشهد ظهور حلول جديده بحيث يكون للمستخدم
همم تقريبا
مفاتيح اثنين ربما قد يكون هذه هذا حل
مناسب ااه
او ربما يكون مفتاح واحد
استخداما ثنائي
المجتمع البيتكوين معروف انه يدافع عن
مبادئ البيتك
وفي بعض الاحيان الا اننا نرى ان هناك
رغبه في عدم
وجود اشخاص ومؤسسات
يؤثرون على البيتكوين وتغيير قوانينها
وقواعدها
وسؤالي لكم ما هي
ادوار التي ترون لشركاتكم همم ان يكون لها
الاثر على البيتكن
وربما هل تاثرتم باي من نقاطي اضافيه هذا
مثلا
بس همم
[موسيقى]
الديمقراطيه والشفافيه
الينا في هذه التغطيه حول القرار ماسك
مراسله العربيه
[موسيقى]
يعني استقالته عن هذه الاداره اداره تويتر
بجلسه مع رؤساء للشركات تفاصيل اكثر حول
هذا القرار الذي سبقه استفتاء طرح وكانت
الاغلبيه تقول او قالت لي ماسك نعم نريدك
هذا القرار اليوم باعلان ماسك التنحي عن
الرئاسه التنفيذيه لمنصه تويتر كان متوقع
بعد الاعلان عن الاستفتاء للي طرحوا قبل
ساعات ااه ماسك على منصه تويتر الكثير من
المشاركين حوالي
حوالي 14 مليون شخص على ما اعتقد شاركوا
بهذه بهذا الاستفتاء و57% منهم قالوا له
تنحى عن منصبك وتنازل عن منصبك هذا القرار
كان متوقع ولكن
ما يجب ان نذكره تحديدا انه ماسك لا ينشر
هكذا استفتاء دون توقع النتيجه فهو توقع
النتيجه وبناء عليها طرح هذا الاستفتاء
الكثير من المراقبون تحدث عن انه الان نحن
ننتظر فقط اعلان همم ماسك عن الرئيس
التنفيذي الجديد لتويتر بعد حوالي شهرين
من رئاسته هذه الشهيره فتره شهرين كانت
مثيره للجدل دائما
لصق وعلي تويتر وليستخدميه تويتر ايضا نعم
اعود الى دكتور احمد يعني هل فاجاك
الاستفتاء يعني
ريتا تحدثت عن نقطه مهمه يعني الان ماسك
لم يكن لي يطرح هذا الاستفتاء لوما عرفتوا
بنتائج بنتائج التي سيكون عليها
عمليه انحدار شعبيته بشكل كبير في المنطقه
اللي احنا فيها همم ظهرت في ظهوره على
مسرح كوميدي وحوالي يمكن 1800 واحد كانوا
يعني مش مبسوطين اني موجود هناك اضافه الى
انه همم المستثمرين عرض عليهم الاستثمار
54$ للاستثمار فرفض الشيء هذا فكان واضح
انه الشركه فيها ازمه ماليه ولما توصل
للمرحله هذه تبدا البوادر تبعته انه اوكي
الى مين المشكله هل هو الرئيس ولا الشركه
كان واضح من البدايه ان الشخص هذا يعني
غير مؤهل على انه يقود الشركه من ال- من
اول يوم الى واليوم الخبر هذه اللي جاء
اليوم هذا راح ناس كثيرين في تسله وفي
تويتر وفي الوادي السيليكون بسبب انه هذه
مش طريقه اداره منصه اصليه
نعم ابقوا معي سنذهب لنشاهد هذا العرض عن
ابرز القرارات التي اتخذها الماسك منذ
تواليه اداره التويتر وحتى اليوم اعلانه
لتنحي
[موسيقى]
من جديد تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه ريتا
سليمان وايضا الدكتور
احمد ما نفع من جديد اهلا بكما ريتا يعني
عندما اتخذ ال الماسك قرارات كبرى مثل
تصريح 50% من موظف فيه تويتر كان هناك
يعني شكوى
وتظلم من هؤلاء همم الناس من هؤلاء
الموظفين وايضا كان هناك استقالات
بمناصب عليا حتى باكثر من دوله فعليا ما
برايك الواقع سيكون الان على هؤلاء حتى
وقع تلك القرارات على الشارع الامريكي
بدات ردود الفعل
تتوالى ان كان من الموظفين الذين كانوا
على مشاكل كثيره مع الون ماسك وحتى من
الشارع الامريكي
خاصه بما اتبعناه في انتظار الاعلان عن
نتيجه الاستفتاء الاخير الكثير من
الموظفين
السابقين في التويتر قالوا انه واخيرا نحن
نرحب بهذه الخطوه واخيرا هذا هو العدل
الان وهذا ما كان يجب ان يحصل همم مقابل
البعض من الامريكيين قالوا بانه هذا كان
تضيع
وقت همم الامريكيين وقت مستخدميه تويتر
وهذه نقطه تراجع كبيره وخطوه التراجع
كبيره للمستثمرين داخل التويتر لانه هكذا
قرار سيؤثر على المنصه ولو على الاقل
لفتره قصيره الجميع بانتظار الاعلان
التالي والاعلان عن الرئيس التنفيذي
الجديد لتويتر لنفهم السياسه التي ستتبع
على الاقل خلال الفتره المقبله نعم انتقل
واعود اليك دكتور يعني فعليا ما سيكون دور
ال الماسك بالقادم من الايام بتويتر يعني
هل سيتنحى بشكل كلي عن الاداره سوف لن
يتدخل يعني تصورك لدور بالمستقبل
في وضع يعني مثال همم هو ينتظر هيكون هو
مثلا رئيس مجلس همم الاداره ويكون الرئيس
التنفيذي لشخص اخر وهو ينتظر فقط في الظل
شوف التصرفات ويشوف كيف يعني تطور الشركه
وايش اللي هيحصل في الشركه وبناء عليه
ممكن يكون يتدخل او ما يتدخل يعني لا يمكن
انه يدفع 44 مليار دولار في في شركه من
غير ما كله راعي فيها لكن هو الان يعني
دكتور اود ان اسالك عنه يعني 44 مليار
دولار
ومناقشات واخذ ورد وكان هناك يعني
تمسك من الانماس بانني اذا تذكر يعني اخر
فتره باني اريد العدد الاصلي للحسابات
المزيفه واطلق وعودا بانه هذه المنصه
ستكون مساحه اكثر حريه اين ذهبت تلك
الوعود
اول مره في حياته هذه هي المشكله فهو
دائما يعني في سبيس اكس وبورنج كامباني
والثانيه يعني وشركه وكل الشركات هذه كان
في عندنا نجاحات فيها على مختلف المستوى
هذه هي اللي فعلا وضحت اللي لهم ماسك
حدوده يعني هذا شيء اكبر منه مش ممكن انه
يتعامل معها زي ما يتعامل مع الشركات
الثانيه
اريد يعني العديد من
الاشخاص من الشخصيات الكبرى همم خرجت من
ان يكون لها حسابات على تويتر وذهبت الى
حسابات اخرى بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تحديدا ما الحسابات البديله
هناك العديد من الصوت التي لجا اليها من
كانوا على خلاف كبير مع تويتر وسياسته مع
ايرون ماسك وسيليا السوري في مخصصه تويتر
همم هناك من توجه خاصه الحساب الاشهر على
الاطلاق الذي تم توقيفه على تويتر مثل
الرئيس دونالد ترامب لانشاء منصات دروس
حساب الرئيس الامريكي ولكن مع الاشاره
بانه الرئيس الامريكي لم يغرد على حسابه
من جديد في تويتر
من المنصات التي يستخدمها الامريكيون همم
هي في الواقع فقط للاستعمال المحل وليست
للاستخدام والتواصل مع الخارج وليست بشهره
تويتر وفيسبوك وغيرها فيسبوك استفادت ايضا
من الازمات المتاليه
لهن ما فات تويتر وخاصه الازمه الاخيره في
ملخص تعليق حسابات عدد كبير من الصحفيين
الامريكيين من الصحف الامريكيه هذه الازمه
تحديدا واجهه انتقادات كثيره ل همم ايلون
ماسك ان كان من حريه التعبير ومنعه من
حريه التعبير ان كان همم هذه الانتقادات
اتت من الامم المتحده او حتى من الاتحاد
كل هذه الضغوط على ماسك عاد هذه الحسابات
من جديد على تويتر نعم همم دكتور احمد
يعني همم هذا همم هذا التراجع هذه
الاستقاله همم مصطلحات كثيره هل يمكن ان
تؤثر سلبا على المنصه على المدى القصير
والبعيد كان بالثقه ان كان بالقيمه
السوقيه لتويتر
على المدى القصير يعني مثل ما تفضله الاخت
الكريمه ريتا يعني العمليه ارتياح بشكل
عام فالثقه يعني الان ممكن ترجع بتاخذ لها
وقت لغايه ما الناس تثق مره اخرى في في
تويتر والحسابات اللي الناس تركوا
حساباتهم بيرجعوا لهم مره ثانيه فهذه هذه
نقطه واحده على المدى البعيد يعتمد على
الشخص الان اللي حيعينوه في مركز الرئيس
ايش بده يتناظره اتجاهه لانه في نقطه مهمه
هنا انه
ماسك اتجاههم وحافظ فكل قراراته كانت يعني
باتجاه اليمين المدير اللي قبله كان
اتجاهه يعني من ناحيه الليبراليه فكل
اتجاهه لحزب الديمقراطي اكثر من اي شيء
ثاني فالرئيس الجديده تبع الشركه هيحدد
اتجاه الشركه هنا ويحدد ايش الحسابات اللي
تجلس والحسابات اللي يقفلوها او يحفظها
مره ثانيه
ريتها من جديد دعينا همم انه لخص الى حد
ما النقاط التي تحدثت عنها غضب همم الصحف
الامريكيه واحيانا همم يعني شخصيات بارزه
بالكانجرس وحتى البنتاجون من قرارات تويتر
اي قرار
صاحبه تويتر لالن ماسك كان الاكثر معارضه
وهجوم كان في هجوم عليه
لا شكل قرار الاخير المتعلق بالتعليق
حسابات عدد من الصحفيين الامريكيين كان
الاكثر اثاره للجدل خاصه مع تعليقه
وحسابات معتبر همم قتل لحريه الصحافه وهذا
امر مقدس هنا في همم هو واشنطن همم هذا
الموضوع والجدل الذي اخذه فهو اصر على
موقفه قالوا ماسك اثار على تعليق حسابات
هؤلاء الصحفيين بقوله انه همم تم تعريض
حياته الشخصيه للخطر نشر همم موقع منزله
همم
للعالم هذا امر لا يقبل به هذا يعرض همم
حياته وحياه عائلته للخطر ااه وهو سبب
الذي ادى به الى تعليق حسابات هؤلاء ولكن
همم
المجتمع الامريكي لم يقبل بذلك الصحفيين
لم يقبلوا بذلك بل شن هجوم مضاد على الون
ماسك وحصل هناك انتقادات كثيره تخطط
الحدود الامريكيه وصلت الى اوروبا والعالم
نددت بقرارات ايلون ماسك وقالوا له اذا
كان هناك اي خطا قدر تركبه هؤلاء الصحفيون
يمكن ان يصحح ولكن ليس بتعليق حسابات لانه
ليس فقط على منصه تويتر هؤلاء موجودون
هؤلاء موجودون في الصحف الامريكيه
وايضا على المنصه الاخرى مثل الفيسبوك
ايضا
فان ذلك ليس همم لن يكون امر سهل ان
تمنعهم عن حريات التعبير وهذا ما اثار جدل
وكان هناك خرج ايضا مسؤولون امريكيون
واعترضوا على ذلك وكان هذا مثل ما نقول
انه الحد الفاصل الذي جعل هذه الازمه هي
النقطه الفاصله في همم في همم ملف الى
الماسكات تويتر تحديدا
دكتور احمد يعني سرعان ما تاثرت وانعكس
قرار الان ماسك بسناحيه عن رئاسه تويتر
حيث افتتحت المؤشرات الرئيسيه في وسط
التعاملات استقرار اليوم الاثنين بعد
اسبوعين متتاليين من الخسائر بفعل ما خوف
من الركود بينما زاد سهم تسلم بعد ما اظهر
استطلاع للراي على الان ماسك الاستقاله من
منصب الرئيس التنفيذي لتويتر اذا ليس فقط
الان اا قرار الرئاسه ذلك بدا منذ طرح
الاستفتاء للتصويت اا سؤال ليك دكتور احمد
يعني ارتفاع باسهم تسلى الان برايك هل
سيكون
سينصب تركيز الماسك على شركات الاخرى على
سبيس اكس وايضا على تسله هل سنشاهد ذلك
نتائج ذلك
خلاص يعني اخذ الدرس
لا شيء يفهم فيه وتسلا ممكن ينجح فيها
ونفس الطريقه معك حتى سبيس اكس هو ما له
دخل فيها كم مدير فيه مدير التنفيذيه هي
اللي تكون فيها يعني هذا بس هو اكثر حاجه
على الكاسله فالان التركيزه وطاقته يعني
ابداعه هيكون في تسله ما يعني يضيع وقته
على اشياء هو عنده مشاكل فيها او حتى ما
يفهم فيها فالان هذا خبر كويس يعني هذا حي
حيساعد المستثمرين في تسلاوعي ساعه كمان
الماركه تبعت تسلا تكون يعني رجعت المركزه
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور احمد منافع استاذ
الهندسه وامن الشبكات في جامعه ساوزي
كاليفورنيا وايضا لكي ريتا سليمان مراد
العربيه
[موسيقى]
لوصول طائره المنتخب الفرنسي لكره القدم
الى باريس وحل وصيفا كما نذكر من مباراه
امس امس المباراه الكبرى بنهائي كاس
العالم بقطر 2022 ضد الارجنتين كانت
مباراه مره ثانيه تاريخيه انتهت لصالح
رفقاء القائد لونا ميسي باضافه اضافه
النجمه الثالثه في تاريخهم والحصول على
كاس العالم فذكر بانه فرنسا كانت فازت
بكاس العالم عام 2018
ثلاث حتى
الرمق الاخير
يعني ابقاء الكاس في باريس ولكن ميسي
ورفقاقه
حاولوا ايضا
وحصدوا هذا الكاس
نذكر ايضا بانه الرئيس امنوي المكروم كان
حاضرا لتشجيع منتخب بلاده
امس حتى انه قال ماسك ايضا كان حادث
عن تويتر
[موسيقى]
اكد الامن العام الاردني ان الادله اثبتت
ان الارهاب المقتول في عمليه القوى
الامنيه الخاصه اخيرا في منطقه الحسينيه
بمعان هو ذاته قاتل العميد الدلابيحه وانا
السلاح الارهابي المقتول هو ذاته السلاح
الذي قتل فيه الذبيحه واكد الامن العام
الاردني انا الخليه الارهابيه التي اشتبكت
معها قوى الامن خططت لقتله
عمليات امنيه مستمره في الاردن بعد ايام
على مقتل نائب مدير شرطه محافظه معان
العميد عبد الرزاق الدبيح ثلاثه من عناصر
الامل قتلوا وجرح خمسه اخرون خلال مداهمه
استهدفت مشتبها به في مقتل العميد
الدلابيح وهم نقيب وملازم وعريف بحسب ما
اعلنت مديريه الامن العام الاردنيه الامن
الاردني اضاف ان المداهمه في معان الواقعه
على بعد 218 كيلومترا جنوب العاصمه عمان
ادت الى مقتل المجتبه به وهو من حمله
الفكر التكفيري كما تم ضبط ثمانيه اشخاص
اخرين مشيره الى ان التحقيقات لا زالت
جاريه
وبعدين ملك الملك عبد الله الثاني حينها
مقتل العميل متعهدا بان ينال المجرم عقابه
امام العداله على جريمه النكره بينما اصدر
وجهه وابناء معان بيانا الجمعه نعوا فيه
العميل دلابيح مؤكدين رفدهم واستنكارهم اي
فعل خارج عن القانون فيما لا يزال الالم
اعتصروا قلب الوالده والده العميد التي
دعت في لقاء سابق مع العربيه الى محاسبتي
لابنها
ربي ربي من فوق ياخذ جزاك ومن كل اهله ومن
كل الاربانه ومن كل صديق له
شقيقه العميد عبد الرزاق ذبيح قال للعربيه
ان عائله العقيد تثق بالاجهزه الامنيه
الاردنيه وتقف مع الدوله مشيرا الى ان
الاجهزه الامنيه اوففت بوعدها واقتصت من
قاتل لبنان
مع الوطن مع الاجهزه الامنيه واصدنا بيان
امبارح اعطينا الاجهزه الامنيه المده
الكافيه من اجل انه اظهار الحق واظهار
القتله القاتل بين ومعلومات اوليه الحمد
لله رب العالمين تم تصفيته
حسب معلومات اللي يعني قراناه وسمعناها من
الناس اللي شروا افضالكم اللي يعني تواصل
قالوا كان امبارح في مداهمه
للموقع اللي تم انه اطلاق النار على
المرحوم
لي
لاستثاث هؤلاء القتله الجنى
ما تقيمك الاولي لما حصل يعني اضرابات من
جهه
واستعمال لهذه الاضطرابات لتنفيذ عمليات
ارهابيه من جهه اخرى كيف يمكن تفسير الوضع
بالتاكيد يعني هنالك مصاران اختلطه ببعضهم
ولكن مظاهرات
واعتصامات نتجت عن اضراب الشاحنات قبل
يعني اكثر من
اسبوعين وكانت في المجمل اعتصامات
واضرابات سلميه لم تتخللها اعمال عنف الا
في حالات قليله جدا لكن يعني اثناء بعد
المباراه او اثناء تم اغتيال الشهيد ااه
يعني عبد الرزاق الدلابيح رحمه الله ويعني
كانت الاشارات تتجه الى خارجين عن القانون
وقام بهذه العمليه وفعلا اليوم تمت مداهمه
همم يعني همم بؤره همم سماها همم الامن
العام مجموعه من التكفيريين وجرى ما جارها
تم قتل المجتبه به وقد جاء في الروايه
الامنيه ان هذا المشتبه هو القاتل الفعل
بعد همم يعني التدقيق والتحليل في همم في
البيانات
تمت همم يعني يمكن فعن ذلك في تداخل
المسارات بين مسار مطالب سلميه نتيجه
الضغوطات اقتصاديه يرفعها المواطنين
للمطالبه بتحسين اوضاع لكن يبدو ان
الخلايا تكفيريه والارهابي دخلت على خط
هذه المظاهرات وتسللت من خلالها الى يعني
حرف
المسار ال- همم السلمي والمطلبي يعني
اعتقد يعني بالنسبه لهذا الجانب يمكن فهم
ايضا في سياق تاريخي المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه منذ عقود عانت من البؤر
الارهابيه صقر الشهداء كثيرون في الكرك
قبل سته اعوام وفي السلط وفي اربد وفي
غيرها منها الاماكن في مواجهه هذه البؤر
الارهابي لا سيما يعني ان بيان الامن
العام ايضا اشار الى ان هذا همم الفاعل
وهو يبلغ من العمر 20 عاما له شقيقه قتل
في سوريا وكان يعني احد المن للعمليات
الارهابيه ولو شقيقه اخر ايضا متهم بال-
اا متهم بالارهابا ايضا في السجون
الاردنيه اعتقد ان يعني الملف همم
الملف الامني اليوم قطوي في همم في هذه
المداهمه وبالتالي اليوم نحن همم يعني
تتجه عن ظلمنا الى الملف الاخر السلمي
الاعتصامات التي
عن الملف الامن الذي طويه
بقتل بهذا الشخص ولكن همم سيد حسين معروف
ان همم القوات الامنيه الاردنيه افشلت
العديد من العمليات الارهابيه لديها همم
قوات همم يعني احترافيه
ومتخصصه وايضا يعني تمتلك خبرات امنيه
استخباراتيا كبرى كيف يمكن لهذه العمليه
ان تحصل يعني هناك مداهمه حصلت وقتل خمسه
خمسه اشخاص ضباط وجرح اخرون الا يجب ان
يكون هناك مراجعات امنيه ربما كي لا تتكرر
هذه الحوادث من جديد
الاولى التي يروح فيها ضحايا من جهاز
الامن العام يعني نتذكر في عمليه الكرك
كان الضحايا الذين سقطوا اكثر من هذا
العدد لكن هذا لا يمنع طبعا من وجود
مراجعات على صعيد
يعني التحقق من المعلومات وهكذا هذه واجب
الاجهزه الامنيه نحن نثق دائما بقدره
اجهزه الانبياء على اجراء مثل هذه
المراجعه على التصدي لملف الارهاب يعني
كما يعلم همم المشاهدون البؤر الارهابيه
همم يعني دائما يعني تتخفى في اماكن سكنيه
كما قال ايضا بيان الامن العام
والحرص الامني على عدم امتداد او على دم
سقوط قتله بين صفوف المدنيين يعني يدفع
هذه الاجهزه احيانا الى التضحيه بنفسه
نفسها من اجل اتمام العمليه انا اعتقد انه
همم يعني لا مجال اليوم في قدره اذا
الامنيه الاردنيه التي اثبتت على مدى
العقود الماضي ان قادره على ملاحقه
الارهابين وهي مشهوره لها بالكفاءه
العاليه لكن لكل قضيه لكل مداهمه لكل
عمليه ملابسات وتفاصيل لا تستطيع الاجهزه
الامنيه حتى ان تطلع عليها
الجمهور شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من عمان حسين
الرواشده الكاتب الصحفي
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
المنافسه في اسواق الاعلانات المبوبه عبر
الانترنت واشاره استخدام مكانتها السوقيه
[موسيقى]
بعد غياب دامس 36 عاما حقق المنتخب
الارجنتيني حلم الملايين ورفع عقائده
الاسطوري ليونيل ميسي الكاس الاغلى في
سماء ستادلو سيل في العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه فرحه عارمه ترجمه عملا جاوبا من
كتيبه ليونال كالوني بدات بخساره امام
المنتخب السعودي
في نهائي تاريخي الانجاز والحلوم الاكبر
كما وصفه قائد المنتخب الارجنتينيه ليونيل
ميسي انه تحقق وتتابعات عاقبه الانتصار
الحلم ردود الافعال من رياضيين واساطير
سابقين وسياسيين ايضا الاسطوره البرازيلي
بيليه الفائز بكاس العالم ثلاث مرات كتب
قائلا اليوم تواصل كره القدم
سردا قصتها كما هو الحال دائما بطريقه
اسره فاز ميسي بكاس العالم للمره الاولى
كما تستحق مسيرته
يا لها من هديه مشاهده هذا المشهد لمستقبل
رياضه تهانينا للارجنتين بالتاكيد دييغو
مارادونا يبتسم الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قائد منتخب ليونيل ميسي اللاعب الافضل في
كاس العالم فيفا قطر 2022 كان هو الحال
خلال السنوات الماضيه حديث المونديال
والصحافه حول العالم هل سيعتزل هل سيكون
المونديال الاخير في مسيره اللاعب
الاسطوره استشف العالم من حديثي ليه وانا
مونديال قطر سيكون الاخير في مسيرته
العبقريه وفقا تصريحاته السابقه لكن
القائد الاسطوري وفي غمره الفرحه العارمه
بتتويجه بكاس العالم امس اعلن نيته
استكمال المسيره مع منتخب بلاده قائلا انه
يود اللعب للمنتخب للمنتخب وهو بطل العالم
بالتاكيد سير غابه كل ارجنتيني باستمرار
القائد ميسي في صفوف المنتخب وكذلك يرغب
محب الرجل حول العالم لكن في المذيعه
المقبل 2026 سيكون عمر ليو 38 عاما ولا
يستطيع احد سوى ميسي نفسه ان يحدد متى
يوقف قطاره مع المنتخب واللاعب الدو لكن
فعلها لوكا مودريتش وكريستيانو رونالدو
اللذين لعب المونديال بعمر 38 عاما و 39
عاما على التوالي فهل ينوي ماس فعلها
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم مشاهدينا رسمها الطيار بوتن
الذي ذهب برحله الى بيلاروسيا حيث رصد
مواقع التتبع الخاصه بالطائرات على مستوى
العالم مراقبه اكثر من 15000 شخص لطائره
الرئيس قبل وصوله الى روسيا وظهرت على
الموقع طائره الرئيس الروسي وهي الاعلى
مراقبه على مستوى العالم ثم اختفت الطائره
بعد ذلك عن الرادارات روسيا اليوم التي
اوردت الخبر قالت انه يبدو ان المسؤولين
الروس لاحظوا مراقبه الطائره قبل الاختفاء
وقام الطيار برسم حرف زاد بمسار الطائره
في الجو للتوجيه رساله للمراقبين
اما تصريح اليوم فهو ليونال سكالوني مدرب
الارجنتين الذي قال ان القميص ليونيل ميسي
سيظل متاحا اذا اراد ان يخوض كاس العالم
المقبله بعدما رفع اللاعب البالغ من العمر
35 عاما كاس العالم
بمساهمته في الفوز على فرنسا 4 2 بركلات
الترجيح وقال اسكالوني في مؤتمر صحفي
اعتقد اننا يجب ان نحتفظ بالقميص رقم 10
ليكون جاهزا في كاس العالم القادمه اذا
شعر ميسي بالرغبه في اللعب
اما فيديو اليوم فهو لي تدفق اسرع اتراك
على معبر صار بالحدودي مع جورجيا لشراء
هاتف ايفون بسعر اقل قبيله راس السنه حيث
من المنتظر ان ترتفع رسوم تسجيل الهواتف
القادمه من الخارج وكانت المعابر الحدوديه
احد هذه الطرق حيث توجه العديد من الاتراك
الى العاصمه الجورجيه لشراء هاتف ايفون 14
الذي يتراوح سعره داخل تركيا بين 30000
و32,000 ليره تركيه غير ان هذا السعر قد
يتراجع الى 15,000 ليره في جورجيا في سبب
الضرائب
البنت
والزميل عادل مساء الخير يا عادل
معركه في اوكرانيا وهي معركه نفسيه اكثر
منها منها عسكريا وبالتالي الى اين ستتجه
وصلت الانصار شكرا